hello would welcome to this video
playing hmm I'll see you toot mm
probably don't pronounce that correctly
so probably get a mainline room let's
see hmm yeah let's not go with my own
line let's go for the brain said
actually play to look at something else
there but a cable team how this game and
pans out first interesting okay it
almost looks like he declined banco
these sometimes can get this structure
from this decline bancos i probably
should have played night h5 that was a
mistake g4 here Wow okay OH
okay so let's see if I can I want night
Jesus at night age seven come on night
age seven mmm yeah King g7 Bishop d7 95
is my ideal scenario but probably don't
get this end and this is this is a super
close position after 95 huh yeah it is
probably the correct move but it is
extremely extremely closed it doesn't
take it I was thinking we'll take it I
don't know but now I can take and go up
church five right
I just wondered why this was some kind
of decision just looked like you have to
take with them in king cakes look
strange but maybe he was just like
looking for his coffee or something so I
get this this bad Bishop traded which is
basically good news it's still very
close this position and wait actually I
can take with the a with the sea pawn
yeah of course I can take with this with
the with the sea pawn because I'm pretty
much assured that those bishops here
will be traded the thing is if I take or
he killin sit down okay if I take only
three can take with the f porn okay I'm
trying to keep this tension here a
little bit and see how he plays I have
tons of useful moves look Haeju f8
bishop c8 all kinds of useful things if
he takes I think I'm probably taking
with the Queen taking taking with the
pawn again it's so closed I mean I can
pile up on the H file but I don't I
don't like to take with the pawn maybe
I'm going with this this assumption but
anyway I still have a couple of other
said useful moves to play and I will
decide if he if he really takes and not
okay it seems like he wants to go King
f1 and so on I wondered about Queen to
f6 if this is an idea one if trading
actually helps him really not sure about
it but it has i mean the waiting game
has its limits and it really has but i
can i can still play a couple of more
waiting moves or improvement most
waiting game is wrong i mean i'm
improving my position a bit but it's not
much I wonder King it to where seems
likely I wonder if Knight f6 or this one
if Knight f6 is actually a move yeah
this is this basically says that does he
have night f5 stuff no I want to go to
age 72 h 7 and then maybe take Queen age
495 maybe I mean the night doesn't have
any other squares available anyway then
this route
calm so he went for it yeah this
probably does not work objectively but
if you are down to a minute you're
probably happy with stuff like that so
what is going on here yeah one of a
sudden this is not so active you know
age 56 for this kind of thing he gets it
back and this is not all that great okay
night at 5i I didn't didn't evaluate
that correctly at first this was really
okay for him so if I go night if 8 i'm
going to trade some stuff or does he
have sacrifice especially five the stuff
i don't think it works so at the end
open he wants to play something to h5 I
have to get this around yeah Bishop here
is covering no wait wait wait let's do
this first then the bishop here ok this
is so close down on them probably either
side cannot do much sure and not trading
is also kind of weird
doesn't want to trade that ok ha no it
does yeah this Ricky Ricky not much
going on here can ever do something
Yemen nights are potentially good better
healing bishops but doesn't even allow
g4 time morning is there something I can
do I mean like wow haha yeah i know but
i wonder if i can still whatever can do
something right to h5 yeah i can get it
to age 5 into f4 wow i was i was
thinking i can i'm getting there in time
but I don't ah I mean I saw the move but
I thought I I'm getting there in time ah
stupid very stupid it was really that
was bad I was really helps in aiding
them I was thinking night a six to be
age but he's of course just too quick
yeah it's this very stupid come on long
haha stupid plane yeah yeah ok this was
um I think draw for the most part around
here I'm slightly better but probably
not much that I can do I'm slightly
better because he cannot change the
structure or the only thing that he has
is this an idea 5 which I probably
should have prevented just just
completely the Edison is possible even
here because I don't get get the King
out yeah probably something like this
and that this is taking this out of the
picture and I should do that I didn't
see that that he's got to get does he
get some age for in all ways and John
that that gives a yeah okay can you have
six wins which and I couldn't attend I
couldn't quite figure out I mean I saw
this but does this just look too
dangerous to me but the engine just goes
here and escapes yeah the moon you know
yeah huh can always do this huh okay so
this was a was an opportunity yeah and
here it seems that Queen age five seems
to win no I unless they made it 95 I was
thinking it is kind of a piece sacrifice
it doesn't work but he gets it he gets
it back you know and ok 9 f8 still seems
to hold first the Queen age five was
given as pretty substantial by the
engine you know age five hey this looks
bad I didn't see that he will get them
get the piece back yeah maybe I should
have looked harder because my initial
reaction was the piece sacrifice does
not work and it didn't work at least the
way he played it and here should go
maybe g4 if I want to try anything I
should go g4 it's still a draw
but Gary have to be content with with
the drone now in this position of much
to do I should probably really play this
more prophylactically and get right at
five out out out of this he could have
done this a little bit earlier even like
here I didn't see that I'm not keeping
the pieces of thing I really didn't see
that but how why does it walk let me let
me I don't quite get it I can take here
you can take yeah okay okay okay mmm now
then then after yeah this is something I
should try to somehow get into my system
that in a position like that this is hyd
end it's difficult for me to keep the
peace oh I didn't sorry guys I'm so I'm
not very I'm not very good with this
clicking clicking the analysis on yeah
he as expected the engine gives me a
slight edge very slight it's kind of
clear because why can only shuffle
around here and I can do something on
the weekend squares and then the only
thing I shouldn't do is allow neither
5-under just favorable there are fain
roll it in fact doesn't work but now it
gets favorable for him yeah it took it
took a while there maybe I should have
thought a bit harder them what I didn't
realize actually is that if i move the
queen king salmon the king is perfectly
safe this is the thing one of the ones
i'm only seven and putting that on f6
this Bishop is not playing at all so
this is fairly simple once once you see
it but i was just kind of yeah kind of
believing him I don't know that bad game
ok guys thanks for watching